la columna vertebral se compone de una
serie de huesos interconectados llamados
vértebras que se extienden desde la base
del cráneo hasta el coxis
cada vértebra se conecta con la anterior
y la posterior en las articulaciones
facet arias lo que les permite moverse
con relación a las demás entre cada
vértebra ósea se encuentra el disco
intervertebral de absorción de golpes
las articulaciones facetaria y los
discos intervertebrales trabajan juntos
para permitir los movimientos de flexión
y torsión de la espalda y el cuello
protegida dentro de la columna vertebral
se encuentra la médula espinal que
conecta el cerebro con el resto del
cuerpo
los nervios espinales salen de la médula
espinal a intervalos regulares
las principales secciones de la columna
vertebral son las regiones cervical
torácica y lumbar
los problemas que pueden ocurrir en la
columna lumbar incluyen las siguientes
afecciones degeneración discal o
spondylus es una enfermedad degenerativa
y artrítica que puede causar pérdida de
la función y de la estructura normal de
la columna
o espondilolistesis una afección en la
que una vértebra se desliza hacia
adelante en relación con la de al lado
osteoartritis de las articulaciones
based arias
una deformidad de la columna como la
escoliosis
o una vértebra fracturada
un médico puede recomendar una fusión
espina lumbar posterior para que la
columna sea más estable y disminuir el
dolor debido a una afección una lesión o
una curvatura anormal para empezar el
cirujano hace una incisión sobre la
columna lumbar
se extraen las superficies exteriores de
los huesos para preparar la fusión
el cirujano coloca tornillos en las
vértebras se colocan varillas a lo largo
de las vértebras y se unen a los
tornillos
el cirujano puede extraer pequeños
trozos de hueso de la pelvis para
usarlos como injertos óseos
en otras ocasiones el cirujano puede
optar por utilizar hueso de donante de
un banco de huesos para injertos el
cirujano coloca los injertos de hueso a
lo largo de la columna vertebral para
permitir que las vértebras crezcan
juntas y mantengan la columna vertebral
estable al final del procedimiento la
incisión se cierra con una sutura